hey guys how's it going guess what I
don't have anything does it work we're
at the forum right now and we're at the
80s party so really Idol choice for
Fears I believe this show is actually
gonna be televised on DirecTV or
somewhere I'll tweet about it but I'm
going to be presenting Billy Idol
onstage is you Rick Springfield no Billy
Idol Boy George I saw him walking
backstage did you get in it I got free
passes really yeah but I'm in the middle
of Fire Emblem so
I can probably take a peek in mine yeah
about this
lay away on your face it's a Virtual Boy
as our next performer its empire star
Estrella
pretty great time at the 80s party now
today I bought something for my dog I
talk about him a lot what the problems
that I've been having with him is he
pees all over himself I don't like
talking about it but I don't know how to
stop it one of those stereotypical
things that you think about when you
think about a dog going to the bathroom
is a fire hydrant so to try this out and
hopefully he will pee on the fire
hydrant instead of himself
we've sported the dog he spoke to the
fire hydrant what does he think of it
he's contemplating what does he think of
it as he asks himself what is this what
is it is this something that I might
like is this a new toy are you just
currently blocking the grass so that I
can't eat it any longer
maduk go potty do you not like the
location I real that's a nice spot I'm
just gonna leave this camera here for a
few minutes and see what he does
whole lot didn't work we're in the car
he couldn't tell Matty and I are going
to a lunch and they actually said that I
can bring my baby Maddie or we went go
on a road trip
I can't see what he's doing so
I hope he's accepted it let's listen to
United States top 50 Samia be work work
work work work work turn left onto South
La Brea Avenue and try open up the chip
house
took a pill in Ibiza to show the VG I
was cool and when I finally got sober
about ten years older but it was
something to can't keep my hands to
myself no matter how hard I'm trying
this is a nice tune once I was seven
years old my mama told me go make
yourself some friends or you'll be
lonely once I was seven years old my
good song very good Jam oh yeah
so kick by the ocean okay when you nod
your head yes but you wanna say no do
you
she knows oh yeah you used to call me
all night Jules - you used another hit
in 1,000 feet turn right you're screwing
up
from me
we start
we gotta stop the tunes because I got to
figure out where I gotta go
I left the meeting and Maddy was so bad
I have to go get him
I got it he's got to go get the snip
snip if you know what I mean
he was so out of control around this
other dog than I
Oh God it was embarrassing it was so
embarrassing stay tuned for that vlog
bye-bye daddy balls he needs a trainer
I'm struggling
we come from the meeting and driving and
whatever this video contains I believe
there's the 80s party there's some
random stuff with Maddie either way I'm
going to edit this video and finish up
tomorrow's check Tuesday also have a
very fun video for you guys on Wednesday
which I'm really excited about so make
sure you guys check that out that's
really all of that for you hopefully I
will see you guys tomorrow tomorrow's
tech Tuesday you'll find out if I keep
the Mac Pro I wonder I wonder what I did
I don't know